[Applaudissements]
on dirait julien lepers
non c'est dégueulasse ah mais tu est
horrible au caire ont un petit tweet
alors stop au visage on commence à
s'approcher quand est ce que le frisé
c'est pas mal lara fabian ville a
renchéri un on a tu vois il est 20h30
talent jusqu'à master 36 hockey bref je
me dépêche alors ce soit drôle ou tuer
je vais dire il vaut mieux faire cinq
minutes bien que cinq heures dégueulasse
ce qui souvent ma femme donc c'est
parfait va être ce soir au programme dès
lors et un animateur qui pète les plombs
en direct le retour du thar baba cyril
hanouna qui doit affronter sa peur des
bactéries et pour finir une nouvelle
enquête de baba ah oui bien sûr sur l'un
des chroniqueurs ici présents dont tout
le monde parle
et alors chaque jour vous le savez je
commence toujours la chronique avec la
vidéo qui fait le fameux ramdam vous le
savez la vidéo dont tout le monde parle
aujourd'hui est extrait d'une émission
que j'ai évoquées hier c'est quoi et oui
c'est l'heure des pros à tes magnifiques
ouais je vous rappelle dans ce programme
c'est tellement le bordel qu'à côté
l'ambiance ici c'est le jour du seigneur
ce matin c'était le summum de la
cacophonie personne n'écoutait personne
et surtout pas le présentateur jour ma
pascal praud le laurier d'animateurs qui
pète les plombs en direct et on t'aime
au salon il va aussi vous savez
[Applaudissements]
non mais enfin je vais quitter le
plateau
les i sava non mais je t'ai pas on
s'entend pas les gens trop se met en
grève
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine des gentilshommes alors on
vient de voir pascal praud s'énerver
contre ses chroniqueurs vous ça ne vous
arrive jamais j'ai dû tout j'adore
pascal il a raison de remettre un peu
d'ordre je devrais je devrais plus le
faire c'est vrai vous d'ouvriers mais
vous êtes quand même le samuel umtiti de
l'émission parce que vous taclez tous
vos chroniqueurs saison des tacles au
genou je trouve c'est incroyable je vous
remets pour la troisième semaine
consécutive le laurier du tabac vous
travaillez beaucoup vous oui à fond
c'est fou mais ça ne se voit pas du tout
[Musique]
vous quelque chose est fait ce week-end
j'étais à bruxelles
ah oui et vous auriez dû rester en perte
et celle de cette rentrée djoudi a eu
très très peu de fierté
il ya eu çà et l'émission de valérie
bénaïm je déconnais les profs dont c'est
comme ça je sais pas mais c'est qu'elle
est dans le regard
vous êtes avait passé une petite s'est
complètement retirée moi ça me va pas du
tout et je trouve que c'est honteux
aussi cher ça marche
oui mais merci on vous rappellera lui
répondre pour lui répondre je viendrai
plus les mercis mis la patte les parties
série vous détestez qu'on vous touche au
kangoo tribot pensif et ça ça vous
énerve pas les bactéries ça vous fait
peur je rappelle vous n'êtes pas dit
donc normal vous n'aimez pas qu'on vous
serez potes c'est comme maxime gainey
mais mardi vous receviez nadia farès et
antoine duléry
mais antoine duléry qui est non
seulement un grand acteur mekkaoui l'un
des meilleurs imitateurs de france
enfin un des mes meilleurs amis dans son
immeuble alors y est très fort très fort
je m'inspire
mardi il vous embrasse et ouais et j'ai
tellement rigolé en analysant la
séquence que je vous remets le laurier
d'animateurs qui est très mal à l'aise
mais qui peut pas le montrer puisqu'il
avec son invité
on se rappelle que marlène schiappa
n'arrêtait pas de vous toucher dans btp
et vous avez trouvé la technique
parfaite veut plus faire tripoter vous
éloigner
[Rires]
alors qu antoine duléry veut vous
embrassez vous êtes en dépression
embrassant la source et pour éviter le
bras le cou vous poussez comment et donc
des lacs discrètement vous éloigner et
qu'est ce que vous faites pour vous
suiviez
[Musique]
je vois tu rien ne m'échappe ou cède
alors à chaque fin de saison pour finir
vous annoncer non mais à chaque fin de
saison j'ai remarqué un truc vous voulez
qu'on se bat tous de l'octogone dans les
médias chaque fin de saison on garde un
mot qu'il fait car elle se sent
anniversaire aujourd'hui dix stations
[Applaudissements]
alors pour terminer chaque fin de saison
vous annoncer dans les médias qui n'y
aura quasiment aucune recrue pour la
rentrée suivante vrai et à chaque début
de saison vous avez embauché toute l'île
de france
la preuve avec cette photo regardez je
suis sûr que vous pouvez même pas me
citer la moitié des noms qui sont au
dessus de la voile à regarder la moitié
chez soi
bref comme de s'envoler bien oui mais
aussi sur d'autres émissions tournées ce
patch est exactement où chez eux
bref un problème que les boutons
problème c'est vrai mais je risque zéro
de les rejoindre très vite attention
bref un ressort à 1 c'est gentil comme
200 recrues estivales ça vous suffit pas
pour tenir la saison vous recruter tout
le temps de nouveaux chroniqueurs
notamment une personne qu'on adore mais
que les gens n'attendaient pas forcément
ici celui qui est passé en une semaine
d'un look de prof de ski de fond à val
d'isère
un look de ministre de la culture doc
gynéco avec tout le monde se demande ce
qui est pourquoi vous l'avez engagé
c'est la grande question pourquoi si on
avait engagé d'objets déco c'est la
nouvelle enquête de baba partie
[Musique]
lui c'est bruno beausir plus connu sous
le nom de doc gynéco eh ouais
le chanteur de tubes inoubliables tels
que ma benz la tribu de dana ou encore
tu m'oublieras
voilà déjà quinze jours que l'homme à la
vivacité semblable à celle d'un escargot
grippe et a rejoint l'équipe ne touche
pas à mon poste 6 irriguera nunaa
décider d'engager cette star du rap
ce serait non seulement grâce à ses
prestations mémorables dont tu balances
ton post
il ya une éco qui s'est endormi mais
aussi qu'un doc gynéco disposerait de
toutes les qualités requises pour
travailler chez nous en effet il ne
connaît rien aux médias et adore porter
des déguisements à la con d'ailleurs il
connaît parfaitement les autres
chroniqueurs jean laurens alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait comment vous l'avez appelé
alors pourquoi cyril hanouna at il
engagé
doc gynéco le dock et il fait ses études
avec jimmy mohamed le cousin de brandon
mahmoud et surtout doc gynéco
réussira-t-il à clouer le bec à ceux qui
disent que sa carrière
tall l'arrêt beaucoup de questions
auxquelles l'inspecteur baba ne va pas
répondre
[Applaudissements]